는요 너희들이 1번부터 19번을
너희들이 파이널 1에서부터
어 3회 어 최종 1회까지 다섯 개
회차의 시험 중에 각 번호 대에서
너희들이 많이 틀렸던 문제들을 배치를
했어요 결국 어 결국 복습이 꼼꼼했던
친구들은 충분히 많이 맞출 수
있었겠어 없었겠어 있었겠지 어 낯설진
않았을 거야 자 필통 치워요 다
집어넣어요
자 시우는 아래와 같이 싸키 나무를
바닥에 차곡차곡 쌓 후 밑면을
포함하여 겉면을 모두 드러내었다 결국
얘는 보이지 않는 싸키 나무를
구하라는 얘기랑 똑같은 거지 그럼이
테두리를 다 없앴으니 여기 한 개
여기 한 개만 남겠어요 안 남겠어요
남겠죠 그래서 답은 모두 몇 개가
되겠어 두 개가 되겠습니다 너무나
쉬운 문제였지
자
그다음 2번
봅시다
자 자 민성이는 집 실드 모의고사를
오후
2시부터는 아 오전
2시부터는
시침과 분침이 겹칠 때마다 한 문제씩
풀었다 모두 몇 문제 풀었을까라고
했지
근데 우는 겹치는 건
12시간에 모두 번이라는 사실을 알
수 있어요 없어요 물론 직각은
22번이 되겠지 맞지 자
그러면 오전
2시부터는 서부터 오후 2시까지는
11번이 될 거잖아 그럼 오후
2시부터는 2시 몇 분 3시 몇 분
4시 몇 분 세 번이 되겠죠 그래서
모두 몇 문제 14 문제가 답이
되겠습니다이 웠어요 자 그다음 3번
봅시다 자 라이는 일주일에 2시간
20분 2시간
20분이면
140분이 거
알아요요 맞지 근데 그거 일주일
있잖아 그럼
하루에는
20분 20분이 되겠어 안 되겠어
맞지 그럼 20분이 모여서 12시간이
돼야 되겠지 얘들아 12시간이
720분 거 알아요 몰라요 알죠
그러면은
720 20으로 나누면 결국 30
6일이 지나야 된다는 거 알 수
있어요 없어요 있죠 그래서 답은
36일가
되겠습니다
어 4번 보겠습니다 자 이런
문제는 자 은규와 연우를 합치면
계지 그럼 우리가 유건이 하고 민재를
합치면 50개
근데 40개 할 수 있어요
없어요지가
개
어면 그 원는 6이 두
50개 내가 지금 이제 얘기하면
되잖아 둘이 합치면 얘랑 70 개야
그 얘는 몇 개야 40개 그래
왜 자 그다음 원이의 구슬 수와 이거
쉬운 문제라니까 그니까이 이점 문제죠
민재의 두배를
합치면래요 면 민제는 얼마가 되겠어
10이 되겠지 그건 원이는 얼마가
되겠어 30이 되겠어요 안 되겠어요
그리고 연우는
원보다 더 가지고 있으니까 40이
나머지 한 명은 누구지
음인가
규는 30개가
되겠습니다
[음악]
자 4로 계속 나눴 때 몇 번째
나머지가 생기겠냐 했지 그러면 우선은
4는 2 곱기 이잖아 그럼 2의
거듭제곱의 개수를 찾으면 되겠지 아
물론 얘는 1에서 500까지 해서
1에서 200까지 빼주면 되겠지 물론
2001에서 500까지 세도 상관은
없어요 해보자 자 2의 배수 4의
배수 2가 세 번이 곱한 8의 배수
그다음 16의 배수 32의 배수
64 256의 배수까지 생각하면
되겠지 자 계산해 주면 이때는
250개가 되겠고요 이때는 125개
되겠지 이때는 얼마가 되겠어 62개가
되겠어요 안
되겠어요 맞지 이때는 31개가 되겠지
이때는 15개가 되겠지 이때는 일곱
개가 되겠지 이때는 세 개가 되고
이때는 한 개가 되겠어요
자 200일 때는 이때는 100이
되겠고요 이때는 50이 되겠고
25개 12개 여섯
개 세 개
마지막에 한 개가 되겠어 안 되겠어
되겠지 그건 여기에서 여기 개수를 빼
주면 되잖아
그런데 또 빼기가 귀찮네 그냥 똑같은
거 지울래 이렇게 지워도 돼요
맞지 이렇게 지어도
되겠어
맞죠 이렇게 지어도 되고 이렇게
지어도 되겠지 그럼 남는 건 얼마야
21에 16개를 더한 297개 되겠어
안 되겠어 자 2가 297개 있다는
것은 4가
148개 2가 한번 더 곱해지는 거지
너희들 보니까 필주 다니는 친구들
보니까 정도이 과정 정도에요 거듭
제곱이 있더라 맞지 프리미어 중국
뒤에도 있더라 그래서 어 거듭 제곱을
설명해도 어 다 알 거 같아 맞죠
그럼 결국 148 번 4로 나눌 수
있다는 얘기지 근데 몇 번째
나오겠느냐고 했으니까
149 번째라고 할 수
있겠습니다 자 6번 보면요 통속에
10원짜리 50원짜리 100원짜리
500원짜리 1,000원짜리
집회가 각 동전과 집회가 각각 여러
장식 있어 아무거나 세 개를 꺼냈
근데 얘들아 여기에서 뭐 두 개 한
개든 뭐든 돈이 바뀌어요 안 바뀌어요
겹치는 돈이 하나도 없지 그러면
여기에서 이렇게 생각할 수 같은 돈
세 개를
꺼내 그리고 두 개 한 개를 꺼내
그지 그리고 한 개 한 개 한 개를
꺼내는 경우가 있 있겠어요 없겠어요
자 세 개를 꺼내는 경우는 모두 몇
가지가
되겠어 다섯 가지가 되겠지 자
그다음에 두 개 한 개는 얘가 두
개일
때는 어네 가지가 되겠지네 개씩 다섯
가지가 있으니까 이때는 20가지가
되겠어요 안
되겠어요 자 여기에서 세 개 고르는
거는 다섯 개 중에 세 개 점 다섯
개 중에 삼각형 그리는 거랑 똑같은
거지 그러면 5 * 4 * 3을 3
* 2 * 1로 나던 거 다 알아요
몰라요 그럼 얘는 가지가 되겠지 그
모두 다 치면
3가지가 답이
되겠습니다 자 다음 문제로 넘어갈게요
7번 자 320 95는 각자리 숫자가
작아진다 근데 600보다 작은 수
얘들아
두자리가
그리고 100번 대가 있겠고 200번
대가 있겠고
맞지 300번 대가 있겠고 뭐
400번 대가 있고 500번 대가
있겠어요
없겠어요
있겠지
자 어 자 두 자릿 수일
때는 10회 짜리가 9일 때는 몇
개야
이렇게 되겠지 그럼 얘는 아니지 9
8 7 6 5 4 3 2 1이
되겠어요 안 되겠어요 그럼 모두 몇
개가
되겠어 45개가 되겠어요 안
되겠어요
어
개요 왜 10 아 깝다 맞지 자
그다음 100번 떼 놓고요 2 1 0
한 개가 되겠지 선생님 집중해야
되는데 그리고 3일 때는 3 2 3
1 이렇게 있겠지 1 + 2라서 세
개가 되겠어 안
되겠어 4 3 4 2 4 1 이때는
여섯 개가 되겠어요 안 되겠어요 5
4 5 3
52 51 이때는 당연히 열개가
되겠어요 안 되겠어요 케 그러면은
답은
65개가
되겠습니다 자 현수는 파란색과 빨간색
시계를 한 개씩 샀대요 자 그런데
파란색은 1분 빠르고 빨간색은
2분잖아 어 그럼
얘는요 한 시간에 둘은 3분 차이라고
할 수 있어 없어 맞지 그건 3분
차이가 모여서 칠판
보세요 8시고 시니까 2시간 차이가
됐지 그럼 몇 분이 흘러야
되겠어 40분이 흘러야 되겠어요 안
돼요 되겠어요 그럼 결국에
빨간색은 1분 빨랐으면 40분이 빨랐
있고 어 아 빨간색이 한다 파란색은
맞지
빨간색은 몇 분 80에 두 배니까
아니 40에 두 배니까
80분만큼 내려갔어 안 내려갔어
내려갔지 근데 문제는
뭐야 현수는 몇 시에 두 시계를
맞췄으니까라고 했으니까 얘는 어떻게
해주면 돼
시에서 40분을 빼 주면 되겠어요 안
되겠어요 되겠죠 7시
야 아 하지
말라지 40분만큼 더 가서 8시가 된
거잖아 맞지 그럼 원래는 40분이
되려면 몇 시간이 지나야
돼 어 40시간이 돼야 되겠지 맞지
그럼 40시간이 흘러서 무엇이 됐어
시시 됐어요 안 됐어요 근데 중요한
건 7시 20분 40시간 전이 되겠어
안 되겠어 이해됐어요 그러면 얘는요
우선 20시간을 뺐으니까 16시간을
빼면 돼요 안
돼요 그럼 19에서 16시간을
빼주면 3시 20분이
되겠지 답은 3시 20분이
되겠습니다
자
9번 24명의 부부가 있대요 얘들아
24명의 부부면 쌍인 거지 그럼 모든
사람이 다른 사람과 수를 하는데
해이가 오전 몇 시에 시작했어 9시에
시작했대 그리고 30초가 걸린대 뭐
그건 중요한게 아니야 30 뭐 나중에
하면 되지 자 24명이 악수를 하려면
24 * 23 나 2가 되겠냐 안
되겠냐 되겠죠 자 그런데 한 번에 몇
상 12쌍이 악수를 하는 거잖아 근데
몇 번 악수하는 이제를 찾아야 되겠지
근데 중요한
거 12번을 악수를 해요 안 해요
부부 끼리는 악수를 안 한다고
그랬잖아 이해 됐어 그러면은
얘는 12 * 23에서 12를 빼는
거잖아 그건 12 * 22가 되겠어
안 돼
근데 한 번에
상이니까 나누기 12를 해야
되겠지 그럼 22번 동시에 일어나겠어
안 일어나겠어 그럼 결국 22 곱하기
3이니까 몇
초
660가구
9시 30초를 왜 도래
선생님
자 21년 크리스마스는 금요일이네
얘들아 일절을 물어봤잖아 그건 1일을
기준으로 우선 맞춰야 되겠지 그럼 잘
봐요 12월
25일 18일 11일 4일까지
금요일이 되겠지 그럼 나는 21년
12월 1일을 알고 싶어 그럼 3일
전이자 아 그럼 뭐가 되겠어 모 수
화 화요일이 되겠죠 그리고 22년
23년까지 생각할래 그 이때는 원래는
더하기 1이 돼야 되는데 12월은
어떻게 6년을 지난 거잖아 그래서
이때는 뭐가 되겠어 목요일이 되겠죠
더하기 2가 되겠지 이때는 더하기
1이 되겠어요 안 되겠어요 그럼
이때는 금요일이 되겠어요 안
되겠어요 22년이 6년이
더하기 아 22년이 아니
바 아까 얘기했어 선생님 잘못
얘기했어
미안 자 이때는 수요일이
되겠지 이때는 목요일이 되겠어요 안
되겠어요 맞지 어차피 똑같아데
자 12월 1일이 목요일이야
그다음 1월 1일 2월 1일 3월
1일까지 해 줘야 되겠지 이때는
더하기 3이지 더기 3 이때는 뭐야
더하기 1이 돼야 되겠어 안 돼야
되겠어 어 아니지 29일까지 있으니까
6년이 있으니까 그럼 여기는 금토
일요일 수요일 다시 목요일이 되겠어요
안 되겠어요 답은
모일
[음악]
자
넘어가
11번 이거 많이 했었지 아 몇 번
했었지 누나와 나는 같은 영양제를
먹고 있대요 누나는 아침에 네알씩
먹었는데 마지막에 두 개가
남았어 알씩
먹었는데 얼마만큼이 남아서 20일 같
먹었잖아 140이 여기는 138이
돼야 되겠어 안 돼야 되겠어 그럼
얘는 결국 학과 차의
배수지 그럼 동그라미 하나가 136이
되겠어요 안 되겠어요 그럼 136 *
4에 더하기 1을 해주면 되겠지 그
6 4
2니까 6이 되겠고요 4 3 12제
그
546 알만큼 있었습니다 할 수
있겠네 이해 됐어 자
12번 자 이거 틀리면 안 되지 이건
뭘 생각하라고
했어 사이의 절반을 생각하라고 했었지
그러면 얘는 전체가 얼마야 21이
21인데 얼마 9를 만드는 거잖아
그럼 12의 절반이 필요하겠죠 그럼
12의 절반은 6 이잖아 그럼 결국
5하고 1을 뺄 수 있고요 4하고
2를 뺄 수 있고요 3하고 2하고
1을 뺄 수가 있겠지 답은 세 가지가
되겠습니다 자 여기까지
정리 복습을 많이 했는지 안 했는지가
눈에
보이지 우리하고 복습을 많이 안 하는
거 아니야
자 13번 다섯 개의 숫자 0 2 3
4 6 중에서네 개를 골라네 자리
짝수를 만들었대 자 이거는 10319
10 문제라고 했지 여러 번 했다고
했어 맞죠 그럼 만들 수 있는
수는 4 * 5 * 5 * 짝수가
되려면 0 2파 7판을 봐야지 그럼
4가 되겠어요 안 되겠어요 그럼
전체는 400개가 되겠지 자 천의
자리에는 2하고 3하고 리이
100개씩 똑같은 개수로 들어 있겠지
무엇의 자리에
전해자 그럼 이거 더하면 얼마가 돼
15가 되나 15의
0이 다섯 개가 되겠지 자 개
자리에는 어
0과 2와 3과 4와 6이 80개씩
있겠지 왜 다섯 개가 똑같은 개니까
무엇의 자리에 100의 자리에 그럼
15 * 8은
얼마야
120이 거기다가 0세 개 붙이면
되겠어요 안
되겠어요 줄을 맞춰야
되니까
이렇게 되겠어 안
되겠어 자 10의 자리에는 똑같이
10의 자리에 있겠지 그럼 여기도 한
자리 뒤로 해서 이렇게 되겠지 하지만
1의
자리에 0과 2와 4와 6이 80개씩
1의 자리 있겠지 근데 여기는 얼마야
어개 아
100개씩 아 자꾸 이번에 버전이
바뀌면서 필기가
지워져 전
업데이트 자 몇 개야 100개씩 1의
자리에 있겠지 그럼 이때는 1200이
되겠어 안 되겠어 그럼 뒤에서부터
더해 주면
되겠죠 이렇게 되겠
아 맞은
사람 얘들아 거는 우리 많이 했던
벤다이어그램
문제잖아네 이렇게 되는 거지 전체를
더하고 겹친 걸 빼니까 얘를 한 번
더 빼서 마지막에 더해 주라고 했었지
그러면 가는 100명 나는 91명
가는
106명에서
62명 75명
67명은
75명 67명을 뺀 다음에 세 문제가
겹치 해를 더했더니 몇 명이 됐어
133명이 돼야 되는 거지 이해 됐어
자 이거를 다 더하면 얼마가
[음악]
될까 297이
되겠지 여기는 얼마야 137 뭐
2천이 왜 나와 자꾸 다 헷갈리게
할래
204가길
93 네모가 133 됐어 안어
어더 빼
6 뭔 소리야
더끼리 더한 거야 왜
그래 세상스럽게 어 중등도 한다는
꼬맹이들 왜 그래 이렇게 되겠어요
안되겠어요 그러면은
명명 겹치는 건 40명이 되겠지 근데
우리가 구하는 건 바로이 부분이잖아요
35명이 가다에서 40명을 빼면
27명이 62에서
더하면
84명이라고 할 수
있겠습니다 자
15번 같은 도로망이 있대요 a
출발해요 점은 지나면 안 되면
뭐야 여기에 우물이 있는
거지 그리고 c n 반드시 지나야
되잖아 우선 a 10까지 가야
되겠네 이렇게 해주면
되겠죠 이렇게 빠져나가서 이렇게 갈
수 있어요
없어요라 여기까지는 다섯 가지가
되겠어 안
되겠어 10이 되겠지 다섯 개가
되겠지 15가
되 답은 15가지가
되겠습니다 자
봅시다 자 1 2 3 4를
나열하는데 두 개 이상 있 수를 지웠
그러면은 내가 1부터 99까지 있어
볼게 그
99에서 아홉 개를 빼야 되겠지
90개가 되겠어 안 되겠어 되겠죠
그다음에 100부터 119까지
보면은 이때는 몇 아 100부터
9까지로 보면 맞지 아홉 개에서 아
개에서 두 개를 빼야 되 지
100이랑 100일 맞지 이때는 여덟
개가 되겠지 근데 110번 때는 할
필요 있어요 없어요 없죠
그래서 120부터 129도 여덟 개가
되겠지 130부터
139도 여덟 개 140에서
149° 여덟개 근데 이렇게
했더니 8 4 32에 122가 됐어요
안 됐어요 그럼 150 부터
159 여덟 개가 돼서 결국에는
아이고 130이 되겠지 그건 두 개를
더해 줘야 되잖아 160 161 돼요
안 돼요 그래서 답은 162가
되겠습니다 자 그다음
넘어가자 17번 성윤이는 원한에
평행하지 않은 아홉개의 직선 얘들아
이건 너무 쉽다 너무 쉬워 하나 했을
때는 두 개지 또 하나 있을 때는 세
개지 또 하나 있을 때는 뭐 얘가
평행하지 않잖아 살짝 만나잖아 밖에서
만나잖아 그래 안 그래 그렇지
그러면은 최 어 최소는 몇 개가
되겠어 열개가 되겠어 안 되겠어 자
최대는 어 1더 기 1+ 2더
얼마까지 9까지 더해야 되겠지 그건
46이 되겠어 안 답은
56 자 18번 이건 똑같이 냈어요
그지 여기서 조심해야 될 건 뭐 두
번 반복한다는 거 있었지 그럼
결국에
싫어 자 이렇게 해서 뭐 한타 어느
학원에서 시험제 나온 적 있어
필드에서
나왔구나
어 자 됐어요 안
됐어요 야
기 그지 이해 됐어 그럼
얘가 이렇게 또 되겠어요 안
되겠어 럼 이렇게
되겠지 하지
마 자 이렇게 되는 거잖아 그럼 봐요
여기에는가 되겠지
마름 모양이 되겠고 얘는 두 배가 될
거잖아 하나 둘 셋 넷 다섯 여섯
일곱 여덟 아홉 열 11 12 13
14 15 17 18 아 17 18
18개가 두 개가 있고 그리고네 개를
더하면 되겠어요 안
되겠어요 답은 40개가
되겠습니다
얘들아 우리가 얘를 반드시 포함하는
거 몇 개야 왼쪽으로 두 칸
오른쪽으로 몇 칸이야 여섯 칸 맞지
위로 두 칸 아래로네 칸이 이제
그중에 빼 줘야 되겠지 세모를
포함하는 건 별하고 세모를 둘 다
포함하는 거잖아 그지 실판네 왼쪽으로
두 칸 위로 두 칸 아래로 세 칸
오른쪽으로 다섯 칸 빼주면 되겠어 안
되겠어 그럼 계산해
주면 96이 되겠지 빼기
60이 되겠어 안 되겠어 답은
36개 물론 공식으로 안 해도 맞는
사람은
있겠지
[음악]
이것
자 여섯개 사고 문제를 50명이
풀었든 맞춘 문제의 개수를 세워보니
178개 모든 학생은 적어도 두
문제를
맞췄지 그럼 두 개를 맞춘 사람은 몇
명이야
16명네 개를 맞춘 사람은
아홉명 그다음 세 개를 맞춘 사람이
동그라미 명이라고 해봐 그럼 다섯
개를 맞춘 사람도 동그라미 명지 그럼
여섯개를 맞춘 사람은 25명을 해야
되잖아 그럼
25명에서 동그라미 두 개를 빼준
사람이라고 할 수 있어요 없어요
그래서 이렇게 합치면 얼마가 돼야
돼 178이 돼야 되는 거지 그럼
얘는요 32고 얘는
36이 결국 동그라미 여덟개 더하기
얘는 얼마지
150이 그리고 동그라미 12개를 빼
줘야 되겠지
이억
50만 어
50만 그렇지 그러면 얘는 합치면
얼마요 68 이잖아 그럼 몇 명이
되겠어 110명이 되겠어요 안
되겠어요 그럼 동그라미네 개 차이가
40이 됐어요 안 됐어요 그럼
동그라미는 10이 되겠어 안 되겠어
되 근데 3점과 5점이 열명 열
명씩이 답은 다섯 명이
되겠습니다
아니에요
끝 자 21번
보자 서로 다른 세수 네모 세모
동그라미를 실로 나는 나머지가 있어
얘들아
네모는 7 * a + 동그라미라고
해도
되겠지
세모는 7 * B + 또 나머지가
같으니까 동그라미로 할 수 있지
별은 7 * c+ 동그라미 할 수
있지 그럼 네모랑
세모랑 별을
더하면 7 * a + b + c +
3 * 동그라미가 되겠어요 안 되겠어
근데 이것이 얼마래
16지 근데 동그라미는 1부터
얼마까지 가능해 6까지 가능하지 그럼
결국에 7 * a+ b +
c
162에 어 빼 주면 되겠지 3 6
9 12 15 18을 뺐을 때 7로
나눠 떨어지면 되겠어 안 되겠어 그럼
3은 안 되죠 6을 빼면 안 되지
99를
빼면
돼 안 되지 12를 빼면 되죠 통과
1일 때 2일 때 3일 때 4 맞지
그래서 나머지는 4가
되겠습니다 5도
된다고 15를 빼면
얼마야 147 이잖아 어 5도
된다 5도 되겠어 안 되겠어 아 두
개 다 떠야지 또 두 개 다야 돼요
어
응 싫어요
상수는
그래 항수
시험은
중학교는 2학년 학생들이 버스를 타고
소풍을
간대 대양 버스는 어 대형 한 되면
여섯 번 중형 한 대면 아홉 번 소형
한 대면 18번이 얘들아 이렇게 해
보자 36명이 있다고 해 봐 그럼
대형은
여섯 명씩 태울 수 있어요
없어요
중형은네 명씩 태울 수
있지
소형은 두명씩 태울 수 있어요 없어요
있지 자 그런데 회사 사정으로 대형은
뭐야 그냥 배수한 거야 맞지 가정한
거야 그럼 대형은 세대니까 18명
중형은 두 대니까 여덟 명을 태울 수
있지
그러면 결국에 명을 태울 수 있어야
되잖아 그래서 몇 대가 있어야 돼
다섯대 자 여기까지 계산 23번
어려워요 맞지 4월
15일부터 6월
14일까지 그럼 4월 달은
몇일이야
15일이지나면
자 5월은
31일이지만 14일이 그럼 며칠이
되겠어 61일 되겠어요 안 되겠어요
그러면 칠판 보세요
24명이 61일 동안 얼마큼 끝낼 수
있는
거야을 10분의 3만큼 끝낼 수
있다고 할 수 있어 없어 그럼 한
명을 61일 동안
얼마야
24분의 3만큼 할 수 있지 그럼 한
명은 61일 동안
얼마야 180분의 1만큼 일을 할 수
있어요 없어요 이해 됐어 그럼 다시
한
명은 1일 동안 어떻게
되겠어 180분의 1에서
6분의 1을 곱해야
되겠지
4880 1을 하겠어요 안 하겠어요
이거는 만두가 뭐 4880 있다고
생각해도 되는 문제야 아니야 되겠지
자 그런데
보세요 6월
15일부터 10월 31일까지 끝내야
된다잖아
얼마만큼을 10분의 7 7만을 끝내야
되잖아 이해 됐어 저
자 그 6월 15일부터 10월
31일까지 몇일이야 16일 더하고
31일
31일 30일 31일 이렇게 더하면
되겠지 더하면 얼마냐
139일이가 어 그럼
24명이네 139일
동안은네 얼마만큼 일을 하겠어 24
* 139 한 명이 4,8 180분의
1만큼의 일을 한다고 할 수 있어요
없어요 그 약분 해주면 8로
나눠주면
610이지 그럼
60분의 417이 되겠어요 안
되겠어요 그럼 전체는 아까 10분이
남았잖아 그럼 여기에서
60분의 417 빼 줘야 되겠지 그럼
얘는
60분의 7에 61 곱하면 얼마냐
427이가 빼기 47이 그 1분의
1만이 필요하겠어요 안
하겠어요 그럼 결국
61분
1을
4880 1로 나눠줘야
되겠지 그럼 결국
뭐야 일 사람 필요하겠어 안
하겠어 그럼 뒤로 가야 되겠지 그래서
8월
13일 어 빨리
하자 자 다과 같은 규칙으로 쓰인
70개의 수가 있대이 중에서 갑은
수는 모두 몇 개입니까 했지 몇
개야 자 하나씩 하자
그냥 들라
쭉 자 합이 2일 때 합이 3일 때
합이 4일 때 합이 5일 때 이렇게
끊어져요 안
끊어져요 그러면은 한 개 두 개 세
개네 개잖아 그럼
70은 66 + 4지네 그건 12번째
묶음의네 번째 수까지 되겠어요 안
되겠어 이해 됐어 그럼 하나 둘 셋
넷 다섯 여섯 일곱 여덟 아홉 열
나까지만 한번
해보자 자 이때는 몇 개 있겠어 한
개 있겠지 이때는 몇 개 있겠어 두
개
있겠지 아 한 개 미안 한 개 있겠지
이때는 몇 개
있겠어 1도 가은
숫자 이렇게 되는 거잖아 맞지 그
이때는 몇 개가 있겠어
얘들아 두 개가 있겠어요
없겠어요 자 그다음에는 5 4 3 2
1 여기는 1 2 3 4 5 이렇게
되는 거잖아 그거 어디서 부터야 세
개가 되겠어요 안
되겠어요
맞지 여기에서 6이라는 여기에 6이
생기는 거지 그럼 이렇게 보면은 몇
개가 되겠어 또 세 개가 되겠어요 안
되겠어요 7일 때는 7이 되는 거잖아
돼요 안 돼요
네 개가 되겠지네 개 되겠지 다섯 개
되겠지 다섯 개 되겠지 이때는 몇 개
되겠어 여섯 개가 되겠지 자
이때는 12분의 1 2 3 4 중에
가분수 되는 거 있어
없어 하나도 없지 거 이것만 더하면
되겠지 그럼 15가 두 묶음에 여섯
개가 되겠지 답은 36개가
되겠 자 사과를
신는데요 매년 두 개의 사과가 열리는
거지 1년 후 2년 후 3년 후 4년
후 5년 후 조용 10년 후가 있어
자 1년 후에는 나무가 몇 개가
되겠어 세 개가 되겠지
어 그다음에 몇 개가 되겠어 아홉
개가 되겠어 안 되겠어 어
그다음에는 27개가 되겠지 그다음에는
81 어 그럼 얘는 3을네 번 곱한
수지 얘는 3을 다섯 번 얘는 3을
번 곱한 수가 되겠어 아니지 사과가
열렸으니까 2 * 3의 10제곱이
되겠어요 안
되겠어요
그러면은 하고 590 49는 우리가
수하에 관심 있으면 이거 곱하면
되겠지
[음악]
정리 이거
짱다네 답이에요 0이에요
어쨌든
이만큼이 무조건 여섯 개씩 있어요
없어요 그럼 어떤 수 곱하기 6인
수를 6으로부터
아 보자 이거는 둘씩 묶어야
되겠지 자 a 아는 조 B 아는 조
C 아는 조가 움직이는 건 3 * 2
* 1이지 근데이 사이에서 왔다 갔다
B 그룹에서 왔다 갔다 C 그룹에서
왔다 갔다
맞지 오케이
맞았다 그 얘기나 그
얘기나 번까지
자 그다음
28번 야
28번은 이건 틀리면 안 되는 거야
밥을 왜 쓰냐고 쓰지 말라고 그 이거
어차피 내가 걷어 갈 거야 그럴
시간에 프리를 집중하라고 이거 내가
걷어 가잖아 프리를 왜 봐 그지 자
얘들아 이거 되게
쉬워 얘들아 아이가 있는 걸 보자
근데 요거 요거 아니니까 한 개나
검은색으로 의심할 수 있는데 아는
뭐야 검은 색이지 그럼 얘는
검은색이야
그 자 하나가 있는 애들을 보니까 a
있어요
그지 그러면요 앞에 있는 건 개수가
되겠지 B 두 개 c 세 개야 그러면
여기는 세 개가 있겠지 자 치가 있는
애들을
보니까 다이아몬 그 검은색 다이아몬
그림으로 세
개
번번
번 얘들아이
문제는 얘들아이 문제는 되게 쉬워
이거 우기기
문제예요 거리가 잘 봐 7 9 14
1개짜리 어떤 동물이 있고
다리가 아홉 개짜리 동물이 있는 거야
그래서 합쳐서 25 마리가 있 그래서
다리 수를 합쳐서 281개 만드는거나
똑같아요 안
똑같아 맞지 그거 우기야 그래 안
그래 자 첫 번째
차이 왜냐면 만 길면 너희들이 포기를
해서 그래
59 45
225g데 세 번째 우리는 2801
구하는 거잖아 255를 225를 빼면
56이 되겠지네 번째 56 나 4가
되겠죠 그럼 14가 되겠어 안 되겠어
그럼 14와 뭐 우게 반대는 생각 안
해도 되겠지
11 당연히 틀리죠 각각이라까지 써
줬으니까 자 마지막
문제 여자 마라톤대회가 이었어요
참가자는 김희성 고소영 시은아 이승현
전도형 최주 이영해 이수영이 이거
지난번
했었는데 이거 다
뭐냐지 지우랑
김도요 한번
해볼까 나 점수를 찮 얘랑
이렇게
되겠지요 사이에 이영애가 있는 거지
저용
맞지
김선하 최지우는 여기 있어야
되겠지
맞죠 자 그다음
보자 김선하 이수영 선수 사이에는 두
명이 꼬리를 할
때 럼 김희선
땡땡 이수영이 수도
있고요
이수영
땡땡 김선일 수도 있어요 없어요 이죠
여기까지 이해 됐어 요거는
끝났어 시문화 선수는 고소영 전도형
다 먼저 꼬리는
때 그 요거 가지고 알 수 있어요
없어요 없지 어쨌든 얘네들은 몇 등은
아니라는 얘기야 7등과 88은
아니라는 사실 알 수 있지 요것도
했고요 고소영 선수는 이수영 선수보다
빨리 꼴이 냈대 그요 앞에 고소영이
있겠어 없겠어 있겠지 그리고 이영의
선수 다음에
김희선 이렇게 되겠 지 그리고 이승현
선수 바로
전에 체지
율에 그럼 최주은 여기 있잖아 그
이승연도 이쪽에 되겠어요 안
되겠어요
되겠지 이렇게
[음악]
되겠어 아 이렇게
되겠지 이해 됐어 어쨌든 김인선 앞에
이형 했잖아
근데 김희선이 최대 갈 수 있는 데는
여기지 맞죠 그건 두 가지 경우밖에
없겠네 이영애가 여기라면 김희선은
여기고 최지훈은
여기고 이승현이 되겠어요 안 되겠어요
그리고
김희선과 이수영
선수 사이에는 두 명 있잖아
근데 이수영은 여길 수도 있고 여길
수도
있겠지 근데 고수 근데 이수영은
1등이 아니니까
여기는 이수영이 되겠어요 안 되겠어요
여기까지 이해 됐어
그러면 이제 남은 건 뭐야 시문화
보수형 전두현이지 그건 시화가
1등이네 자 고수형 전두영 몰라 근데
고수형 이수보 빠르잖아 여기가 보수형
뭐야 꼴등
누구야
전도연이 근데 우승자와 7등 차래
시문 이수영
5등
정리